l'arte in ogni sua forma declinazione da
sempre il più potente ed efficace mezzo
di comunicazione un linguaggio
universale
brave le barriere linguistiche l'arte è
in grado di esprimere le mille sfumature
dell'animo umano e per me è da sempre
una passione ed una necessità
trovo che oggi così come un tempo
comunicare e di conseguenza a suscitare
sentimenti e reazioni nello spettatore
sia il fine ultimo di tutte le
espressioni artistiche
la prima esigenza dell'artista è quello
di esprimere il proprio pensiero il
proprio punto di vista su un micro macro
argomento più il messaggio dell'artista
risulta semplice efficace ed universale
maggiore sarà il numero di persone che
si sentiranno toccate da quell opera con
il passare del tempo abbiamo assistito
ad un'evoluzione nella fruizione
dell'arte da parte del pubblico per
ammirare un'opera d'arte siamo stati
abituati a recarci in dei luoghi fisici
adibiti a quella funzione come le
gallerie d'arte pinacoteche musei chiese
ora abbiamo la possibilità di ammirare
la vastità dei beni artistici italiani
ed internazionali
rimanendo comodamente seduti sui nostri
divani attraverso infatti i tablet
computer e cellulari
abbiamo l'accesso a tour virtuali di
mostre musei con google art project
abbiamo la possibilità di ammirare da
vicino e nei minimi particolari dipinti
di rara bellezza
certo io rimango dell'idea che la cosa
migliore da fare sia quella di recarsi
fisicamente nei luoghi che ospitano le
opere d'arte e di vivere un'esperienza a
360 gradi
l'avvento di internet ha permesso a chi
come me svolge una professione legata
all'arte di raggiungere un certo numero
di persone semplicemente postando i
propri lavori sui social e sulle
gallerie online sono infatti distanti
ormai i tempi in cui andava in giro con
il portfolio sottobraccio bussando le
porte delle case editrici o dei
potenziali clienti chiedendo
disperatamente un colloquio con l'art
director
detto questo bisogna dire che nonostante
l'avvento di internet
ancora oggi procurarsi i clienti e nuove
commissioni è comunque qualcosa di
complicato i rapporti umani hanno il
loro peso anche nei rapporti
professionali e quindi un paio di giri
alle fiere di settore più importanti
sono sempre raccomandati l'incontro
giusto quattro chiacchiere qualche
stretta di mano ma che però al momento
rimanderei a data da destinarsi visto il
periodo storico che stiamo vivendo
allora mi presento il mio nome franco
rivoli sono l'illustratore svolgo questa
professione da circa vent'anni e mi
occupo di copertine libri di scolastica
libri per ragazzi riviste tarocchi
giochi campagne pubblicitarie da
svariati anni lavori digitale
utilizzando strumenti come tablet
computer e tavoletta grafica la
tavoletta grafica permette
all'illustratore o artista digitale di
realizzare ciò che normalmente farebbe
su tela o carta o altro supporto fisico
utilizzando dei software che imitano la
pittura tradizionale acrilico tempera
olio acquerello sono spontaneamente
passata digitale nel momento in cui ho
realizzato le enormi potenzialità che
questo mezzo offriva infatti il fatto di
non essere vincolato ad un supporto
fisico e alle inevitabili tempistiche di
asciugatura della pittura tradizionale
permette di realizzare lavori in tempi
molto più brevi ed inviarli comodamente
con un click da casa è semplicemente il
giorno anche il giorno stesso della
consegna stabilita con il cliente la
velocizzazione del processo di
lavorazione ha però anche i suoi
svantaggi infatti i clienti hanno
drasticamente ridotto le tempistiche di
consegna sottovalutando però un concetto
fondamentale per realizzare un buon
prodotto il tempo è una conditio sine
qua non vorrei tenere inoltre a
precisare che lavorare in digitale non
significa sedersi comodamente la propria
scrivania e schiacciare un enorme
bottone rosso con su scritto crea
aspettando che computer realizzi per noi
l'illustrazione dietro ad ogni lavoro
che poi voi vedete pubblicato su una
copertina su una rivista su un gioco
altro ci sono uno studio profondi
approfondito ci sono sacrifici c'è
frustrazione e c'è anche una costante
ricerca non si smette mai infatti di
imparare l'artista in generale
illustratore e non è mai completamente
soddisfatto del proprio lavoro vive un
costante conflitto tra ciò che vorrebbe
realizzare e ciò che effettivamente
realizza questa è una lama a doppio
taglio da un lato ci spinge al
miglioramento sia il suo tecnico
comunicativo e dall'altro invece la
frustrazione e ci accompagna come una
fedele amica e conviverci non è mai
facile
non so se avete fatto caso ma nella
nostra società le persone con le quali
interagiamo
se non sembra volerci incasellare tu sei
di quanti anni hai
che lavoro fai ecco alla domanda che
lavoro fai non so mai esattamente cosa
rispondere se avessi potuto scattare una
foto ad ogni singola espressioni con
vista dipinta sul volto del mio
malcapitato interlocutore alla risposta
sono un illustratore ora avrei un album
fotografico divertentissimo che tutti mi
vide oreste in pochi infatti conoscono
la figura dell'illustratore vedete i
nostri lavori ovunque ma nessuno o quasi
sa della nostra esistenza
personalmente sono un po allergico alle
etichette e alle necessità di
incasellare le persone in dei ruoli
specifici
credo che la cosa più importante sia
ricordarsi chi si è e da dove si viene
non sono un ruolo sono una persona nella
mia professione l'aspetto fisico per
esempio non conta assolutamente nulla
poi essere alto basso magro grasso
giovane vecchio ciò che mi identifica e
mi definisce come professionista sono i
miei lavori sono le mie illustrazioni a
parlare per me nel mio lavoro è
necessario a costare ad una qualitativa
produzione artistica anche una certa
professionalità che significa ascoltare
e comprendere e soddisfare le esigenze
del cliente e rispettare chiaramente le
tempistiche di consegna
i social network sono potenti mezzi di
comunicazione in grado di offrirci
enormi possibilità illustratori io gli
artisti in generale vengono
costantemente invitati ad utilizzare i
social ad alimentarli quotidianamente ad
intrattenere rapporti con i followers
cercando di agganciarli di nuovi i
social permettono di promuovere la
propria arte e di farsi conoscere
puoi essere l'illustratore l'artista più
bravo del mondo ma se il mondo non sa
che tu esisti nessuno verrà
spontaneamente a bussare alla tua porta
lavoriamo incessantemente nel tentativo
di raggiungere un pubblico più vario e
più vasto assicurandoci così un maggior
afflusso di lavoro farsi conoscere non è
cosa facile possono passare cinque dieci
o vent'anni e può anche non accadere mai
ogni artista ha una storia a sé unica ed
irripetibile irripetibile così come lo
sono le persone magari però sei
fortunato è il primo poi accade e accade
sempre quando meno te l'aspetti
quando il tuo tempo doveva essere
dedicato a qualcos'altro oa qualcuno che
in quel momento aveva la priorità ma non
puoi
accade e basta avevi fantasticato su
quel fatidico giorno l'aveva fatto tante
volte più volte al giorno ma neanche la
tua fervida fantasia si era riuscita
neanche vagamente ad avvicinare a quello
che effettivamente sarebbe stato a me è
accaduto recentemente una mia
illustrazione è diventata virale e la
sensazione è quella di essere
letteralmente folgorato da un fulmine
da un paio di mesi mi sembra di vivere
la vita di qualcun altro per viralità di
un'immagine o di un opera si intende la
sua massima condivisione da parte degli
utenti che ne determinano la popolarità
in generale manca una cultura
dell'immagine e non esiste un vero e
proprio rispetto per gli autori
pensavo fosse libera non sapevo fosse
sua l'ho vista in internet e l'ho presa
ecco questo proposito vorrei dire un
paio di cose molto semplici se non avete
voglia di fare una ricerca di risalire
alla fonte e quindi all'autore è molto
semplice
l'opera non la utilizzate
se altrimenti riuscite a risalire
all'autore e l'unico modo per
utilizzarla è quella di chiederne
l'autorizzazione
tutto il resto non è ammesso tutti gli
artisti a mio avviso mantengono una
forte relazione col proprio bambino sono
persone ricettive sensibili ea volte
anche fragili quando vi comportate in
maniera scorretta volontariamente o
involontariamente ricordatevi sempre che
da qualche parte c'è un autore che sta
soffrendo nel vedere maltrattato
mutilato ho utilizzato impropriamente il
proprio lavoro
grazie comunque questa massiccia
condivisione ho avuto modo di conoscere
persone fantastiche che mi hanno aiutato
supportato sostenuto e soprattutto
rispettato ed inevitabilmente ho
conosciuto anche tutto il lato negativo
di un'esposizione mediatica così
esagerata una sera come tutte le altre
sei lì tranquillo
la seduta il tuo computer stai ultimo
lavoro personale è come hai fatto altri
milioni di volte mi dici di postarlo sui
tuoi social nell'arco di una notte di
poche ore la tua vita è completamente
stravolta telefonate e mail messaggi il
telefono frigge e tu non riesci a
realizzare esattamente cosa stia
accadendo
ero felice certo non mi sentivo anche
spaventato e frastornato avevo la netta
percezione che tutto ciò che stava
accadendo fosse molto più grande di me
e che non fossi strutturato pronto per
poterlo affrontare il mio lavoro era
diventato virale in poche ore ne avevo
perso completamente il controllo
ricordate non si sa quando come o perché
accade forse questa è la cosa più
affascinante dell'arte la sua
imprevedibilità